THE TRAITOROUS EIGHT:
These 8 backstabbed their professor
and created their own company using his research.
While that sounds pretty bad, they weren’t exactly
trying to screw over their professor. They
just wanted freedom and the ability to lead
their own company. Little did they know that
this betrayal would end up being the foundation
of not just Silicon Valley but modern tech as a
whole. Why you ask? Well, these were the men who
commercialized semiconductor technology or silicon
wafers hence the name silicon valley. Also,
you know how there’s a bunch of debate regarding
who’s the better chip maker AMD or Intel? Well,
these guys created both. In fact, they also played
integral roles in the creation of Apple, Google,
Oracle, Facebook, Cisco, Applied Materials,
Nvidia, Juniper Networks, Sun Microsystems,
Netscape, and all of these other companies as
well just to name a few. But, despite their
revolutionary contribution to the tech scene,
unless you’re a tech scholar, you’ve probably
never even heard of them. I mean, have you ever
heard of Sheldon Roberts or Eugene Kleiner or
Julius Blank? Or what about their professor
William Shockley? I’m gonna guess probably
not. So, here’s the insane untold story of the
traitorous 8 and the creation of Silicon Valley.
THE SILICON MAN:
Taking a look back, the story of Silicon Valley
can be traced back to a man named William Bradford
Shockley Jr. He was born on February 13, 1910 in
London, but most of his childhood would be spent
in the family’s hometown of Palo Alto, California.
Shockley didn’t have the strongest of backgrounds,
but he definitely had grit engrained in his
blood. His father worked the dangerous job
of being a mining engineer and his mother
followed in the same foot steps. Fun fact,
his mother would became America’s first female
deputy mining surveyor. So, these guys were very
much about the no pain no gain mentality and they
expected nothing less from Shockley Jr. In fact,
they would recruit a Stanford profesor who lived
nearby to teach Shockley physics at a very young
age. Clearly, getting Shockley educated was a top
priority for his parents, but they weren’t exactly
fans of the public school system. They actually
particularly hated public schools and this was the
main reason that Shockley was homeschooled until
the age of 8. This also played well with the fact
that Shockley regularly had violent tantrums
and didn’t get along with other children all
that well. It looks like this was something that
Shockley never really left behind, but anyway,
it looks like Shockley more than fulfilled his
parent’s dream as he didn’t just get educated,
he became a genius. He would graduate from
Caltech in 1932 with a bachelors and MIT
in 1936 with a PhD. And after graduation,
he would turn around and join the highly
prestigious Bell Labs. If you don’t know about
Bell Labs, think Google Moonshot factory but
100 years ago. Shockley stuck around here for
a couple of years until WW2 broke out at which
point he became a reserach director at Columbia
University. His job was originally to develop
radar technology that could detect submarines, but
he ended up becoming quite close to war leaders.
In fact, the War Department asked Shockley to
estimate the death toll of a certain explosion
that marked the end of WW2. Anyway, Shockley
would return to Bell Labs following the war and
begin reseraching transistors. Spoiler alert, this
research would end up creating modern technology,
but it was by no means a fast or easy process.
In the early days, Shockley saw nothing but
failure with his external electrical field
experiments on semiconductors. But, over time,
Shockley and his colleagues were able to eliminate
one concern after another and they created the
junction transistor in 1951. The creation of this
transistor was very much a team effort between
Shockley, John Bardeen, and Walter Brattain. But,
the media often gave all the credit to Shockley
given that he was the leader. Shockley would
go out of his to give credit to his partners
whenever possible. But Bardeen and Brattain still
felt pretty resentful, and they would both end up
leaving in the 1950s, but Shockley was just
getting started. In 1956, Shockley, Bardeen,
and Brattain would be awarded the Nobel Prize
for Physics. So, clearly, these guys were no
doubt world class, but with Bardeen and Brattain
gone, Shockley needed a new team. This time,
he opted to recruit a bunch of PhD students
instead of already distinguished researchers. He
probably thought that he would have an easier time
managing students than peers. Oh how wrong he was.
THE BETRAYAL:
Shockley would found Shockley Semiconductor
Laboratory in Mountain View, California in 1956.
He would go onto recruit a bunch of PhD students
and recent grads to the company. Their goal was to
make ground breaking discoveries regarding silicon
wafers. Let’s just say, they definitely ended up
accomplishing this, but it was by no means smooth
sailing. You know how we talked about Shockley’s
violent tantrums as a child, well, these
characteristics were only magnified at Shockley
Semiconductor, and the reason isn’t rocket
science. Shockley had literally won a nobel price
by the age of 46, so he felt like he was the daddy
of the semiconductors as whole. And technically,
he wasn’t wrong, but that by no means excuses his
behavior. Shockley has been described as the worst
manager in the history of electronics. He was
autocratic, domineering, erratic, hard to please,
and highly egotistical just to name a few traits.
But, to be honest, that’s not all that different
from Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos or Bill
Gates or really any well known figure. Not being
like this is really the exception when it comes
to figures like this. But, you could definitely
say that Shockley took this to another level.
For example, all phone calls in the company were
recorded, staff weren’t allowed to share results
with each other without Shockley’s permission,
and Shockley even threatened to use lie detectors
at one point. This lack of trust wasn’t exactly
the characteristics of a great boss, but what
really screwed over Shockley was his vision
for the company. You see, 8 of Shockley’s best
researchers felt that the company should focus
on silicon base semiconductors and commercialize
the idea, but for some reason Shockley didn’t want
to pursue this idea. This simply led to even
more disagreements and bad blood and it wasn’t
long till reserachers started resigning. Most of
them would just go ahead and join laboratories
and research teams in adjacent fields. But,
our traitorous eight didn’t want to pursue a
different field. They could see that Shockley had
a winner, it just had to be executed correctly.
The group described it as solving the “Shockley
problem”. They’re first instinct wasn’t to
leave though. They actually tried talking to the
investors of Shockley Semiconductor and asked them
to reign in Shockley, but they weren’t exactly
onboard with this idea. So, our traitorous 8
decided to find their own investors in March
of 1957. The man who pulled the trigger was
Eugene Kleiner. Kleiner was one of the few people
Shockley trusted, so when he requested a few days
off to visit an exhibition in LA, Shockley didn’t
think twice. But, maybe he should’ve as Kleiner
would end up traveling to New York instead and
pitching to investors. Finding an investor was
actually super difficult. It’s not that investors
weren’t interested in the idea but they wanted
something that was closer to home. Trying to
manage these braniacs in California from New
York seemed like a daunting task to say the least.
But, they eventually found someone who was willing
to take the plunge: Sherman Fairchild. Sherman
agreed to loan our 8 protagonists $1.38 million
or the equivalent of $14.8 million today. And with
that, Fairchild semiconductor was established and
the 8 geniuses from Shockley Semiconductor
would officially become the traitorous 8.
FAIRCHILD THE BRAINCHILD:
Our 8 would instantly get to
work on commercializing silicon wafers. Their
first goal was to produce silicon wafers for
digital devices based on the research of Bell
Labs and Shockley. I do gotta say though, they
didn’t rip off the tech completely. They would
actually try to improve it themselves to build an
even bigger lead. They would set out on improving
the technology using three different methods each
of which were led by one of the traitorous 8. The
method that ended up coming out on top was the one
that was led by Gordon Moore. If you’ve ever heard
of Moore’s law, well this is the guy. Fairchild
would go onto implement Moore’s discoveries
into Shockley’s research and within no time,
the company was mass producing silicon wafers.
And let’s just say, Fairchild destroyed the
competition. Throughout the early 1960s, they
were the undisputed king of semiconductors. But,
obviously the company didn’t keep this lead
as they have since disappeared into oblivion,
so what happened? Well, it was the greed of
Sherman Fairchild. You see, one of the conditions
of funding the company was that Sherman reserved
the right to buyout the stakes of the partners
at any time. Ideally, this clause was in place so
that Sherman could easily manage any bad actors.
If someone was causing issues and not being a team
player, well then, Sherman could just buy them
out. But, the problem arose when Sherman started
buying out partners just because he could. It’s
no wonder why Sherman decided to do this. From his
perspective, Fairchild already had a massive lead.
So, he no longer needed the assistance of the
traitorous eight. You could say the traitorous
eight got a taste of their own medicine but
not really. The problem with Sherman’s theory
was that he was just straight up wrong. The
reality is that a lead within the semiconductor
industry doesn’t mean anything. Moore’s law
suggests that the number of transistors in
a circuit doubles every 2 years. There’s some
debate about whether this is still true today,
but it was more than true in the 1960s. In fact,
transistors were doubling every single year,
and the reason Moore’s law states every 2 years is
because Gordon was trying to be conservative. So,
while Fairchild did have a massive lead, if they
slept for 1 year they would lose it all, and
that’s exactly what happened. As Sherman bought
out the stakes of the traitorous eight, they
would slowly leave 1 by 1, and by the end of the
1960s, they were all gone. From there, Fairchild
would begin its descent towards irrelevancy,
but our 8 heroes were far from being done.
UNBREAKABLE LEGACY:
Likely the two most notable
men from the traitorous eight are Gordon
Moore and Robert Noyce. In 1968, this duo
would go onto found Intel, you may have heard
of them. Ironically, their biggest competitors,
AMD was also founded by ex Fairchild employees.
In fact, it was created by Jerry Sanders and 7
other ex Fairchild employees. You could say that
these were yet another traitorous 8. It doesn’t
stop with just Intel and AMD though. Yet another
tech company created by these eight is Amelco.
4 of the original eight: Jay Last, Jean Hoerni,
Eugene Kleiner, and Sheldon Roberts founded this
company and it would eventually become modern
day Teledyne. You probably haven’t heard of
this company, but they’re worth $20 billion. Some
of the other members from the original 8 ended up
taking another path. Eugene Kleiner for example
founded his own VC firm with the help of Tom
Perkins. And these guys would go onto fund/create
Compaq, Intuit, Netscape, Sun Microsystems,
Amazon, and dozens of other smaller companies.
In the meantime, another one of our heroes,
Victor Grinich, would go on to become a professor
at Stanford where he published a textbook called
Introduction to Integrated Circuits. This textbook
would become the basis for how circuits are taught
in schools and universities around the world.
So, who knows how many tech geniuses this guy
inspired. Probably the least accomplished of
the 8 but still super accomplished is Julius
Blank. After Fairchild, he become a consultant for
startups and eventually retired in a retirement
home right across his office at Fairchild. Also,
if you’re wondering about Shockley, he never
understood why these 8 left, but without a strong
team, he couldn’t really make much progress,
and he would end up as a Stanford professor just
like his neighbor from his childhood. But, while
Shockley never hit the mega jackpot himself and
though he had some rather odd perspectives, his
contribution to the tech world is unquestionable.
It was from his little lab in the 1950s that the
entirety of Silicon Valley was born and that’s the
story of the traitorous 8. Did you know about our
heroes or I guess our anti heroes? Comment that
down below. Also, drop a like if you wanna hear
more untold tech stories. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.